Pedro Pascal goes through the ringer in
his Mandalorian costume our guy is
basically blind in that thing he's got
no peripheral vision and only has one
little fogged up slit in the helmet the
costume naturally weighs a ton but
luckily there are some super talented
body doubles who give him a break from
time to time let's talk about the first
major Pitfall yeah obviously the
Mandalorian costume looks very cool even
to the point where Pedro Pascal says it
makes him feel protected powerful and
dangerous but the guy is blind in there
not only does he have no peripheral
vision while he's got the helmet on but
he's just looking through one tiny
narrow slit that is often fogged up by
his own breath he's even said that he's
so blind if there's a hole in the floor
he's most definitely gonna be the one to
fall into it I mean this comes as no
surprise the thing looks like it weighs
a ton he describes it as putting on a
head to toe glove with heavy weights on
it the costume designers have tried to
manipulate and change the costume to
make it more comfortable for him but it
hasn't been as successful as he'd hoped
he's described the work they've done on
the costume as sort of surgical because
there was so much attention to detail to
get the correct portrayal of the
character unfortunately though a lot of
those aspects came with a lot of weight
to carry and unfortunate Vision
restrictions one thing he does like
about it is that it completely engulfs
him in the character really giving him
the experience that he is the
Mandalorian he just you know can't see
or move around too well so because of
how uncomfortable the suit is he
actually has two body doubles to take
some of the weight off he's got Brendan
Wayne an actor producer and Grandson of
John Wayne as well as Latif Crowder an
actor stuntman and martial artist it's
such a collective effort and the suit
ends up doing so much of the work due to
the fact the Mandalorian Clan has strict
rules saying that they can never remove
their Helmet or show their face to
anyone it gives a lot of room for other
actors to give poor Pedro a break from
his sensory deprivation outfit even if I
can't fit into the suit somebody can
also yeah he's not always the one in the
suit but he does do every voice line of
din jarin's dialogue and speaking log
let's talk about one other thing Pedro
Pascal dislikes about playing the
Mandalorian well technically it's not
about playing the character on set but
what fans ask him for outside of work
Pedro says one of the worst things a fan
can ask him if they see him in public is
to do the Mandalorian voice he says it's
just plain creepy and doesn't work in
real life without the mask it just
sounds porny he describes it as this low
register bedroom voice and when parents
come up to him and ask him to do the
voice for their kids it's just extremely
uncomfortable the next thing I know I'm
FaceTiming with a six-year-old who has
no idea who I am because my character
wears a mask for the entire show he also
says it must look super awkward for
whoever's walking by because he's just
like whispering to a kid I can bring you
in warm or I can bring you in cold so
Pedro is always joking around on set
about how he's gonna need an MRI after
the shoot's over we were always worried
that it could be a little Bobble heady
so obviously we know the helmet very
rarely comes off and because of that
that they need to put a mic pack inside
the helmet so it can catch all of his
dialogue and yeah the helmet doesn't
come off when the cameras are rolling
but it comes off a lot in between takes
so literally every time he takes the
helmet on and off the mic pack is
rubbing against his skull in a pretty
uncomfortable way so he always leaves
work with quite a bit of head pain poor
guy okay so not only can our guy barely
walk barely see and has a huge mic pack
rubbing against his skull sometimes he
can't even breathe in there he is truly
so restricted and fogged up at all times
it's hard to actually gather a deep
breath under it all it's also kind of
interesting because he's so immersed in
this experience because of the nature of
the costume it's kind of like this is
the actual existence of someone in the
Mandalorian plan it's fascinating to be
under the kind of physical stress which
I think for so many actors that's a part
of it but to go into such a complete
version of that experience it was
challenging uh yeah I'm definitely
taking the Mandalorian off of my
Halloween costume costume list I really
gotta hand it to Pedro for playing this
character so well considering he's
falling into holes and looking through
breath fog just to get across the set
luckily he's got those body doubles to
give him a hand and now we all know not
to ask him to do his creepy Mando
bedroom voice out in public but what do
you think is the hardest thing about
playing Nando